hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game uh sorry there's a rui Lopez
On The Board already uh between
Christopher you and Han smoking Iman
from the Marshall Grandmaster Norm
tournament that was played in 2020 where
young International Masters were invited
to try and win a win a norm uh and
there's been a lot of talk about this
game lately so I decided to also uh
enjoy it so let's check it out so
Christopher has the white pieces and he
opens with Ponte E4 we have E5 by Hans
Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and yes Bishop
to B5 Dory Lopez is on the board we have
Knight to F6 uh going for the Berlin
defense and now Ponte D4 trying to throw
hunts off guard as this is only the
fifth most popular reply against the
Berlin defense he captures on D4 and now
now Christopher just castles we have
Pawn the A6 challenging the bishop
Bishop to A4 D6 and now with the delayed
capture on C6 Bishop captures on c6b
captures and Knight adapters on the
force all been played before nothing new
here threatening to pick up the the
opponent C6 so Bishop to D7 hunt will
play C5 kick away tonight and then put
the bishop on C6 to gain control over
this diagonal Queen to F3 and now Pawn
to C5 as planned with Knight to F5 and
there are a couple of games for Bishop
captures and F5 was played but Hans has
a different idea Hans play spawn to H6
and it is now as of move tender we have
a completely new game and okay of course
Bishop is coming to C6 the pawn will
uh come under Fire so Rook to E1 and
Bishop to C6 and now just Queen to C3
now moving the queen away from the
defense of the E Pawn but of course uh
you are never considering actually
capturing this as your king is still an
E8 so here Queen to D7 and now Pawn to
F3 strengthening D for pawn queen side
castles and now we get to the moment of
the game where uh things start to get
very very interesting now white uh is
Castle kingside black Castle Queen side
and also hans's Queen side is a bit
ruined uh but a white is uh behind in
development or maybe not behind he just
doesn't have everything uh sufficiently
developed start some sort of an attack
but also you can just uh you know start
developing Bishop to E3 you develop the
the Knight Rook you start pushing some
pawns anything is possible here however
he decides to go for Bishop cappers and
H6 and while this does win you upon of
course if G captures then just Queen
characters and F6 uh hunt says I'm of
course not interested in that but thank
you for opening up the H file for me and
he strikes in the center with the D5 and
now how do you play this how do you
react to this uh Center being attacked
it's not easy plus also there's the
there's the G7 Pawn do do you capture on
G7 well it's not all that clear so what
you could do here is of course play
something like Rook to D1 you put the
Rook under D file then the pawn cannot
capture as the queen is on D7 and then
of something like Knights the H5 uh
adding a Defender to the G7 pawn and
then the game might continue with
something like Bishop to C1 and okay the
the game continues Hans did get the open
H file white is up a pawn but after D4
it this doesn't feel all that
comfortable for white so that's one way
to do it Christopher on the other hand
after this D5 move decides the capture
on G7 which opens up the G file for the
black Rooks as well uh Bishop captures
on G7 Knight caprese and G7 and now the
Knight on F6 is hanging and this is
probably why what Christopher was hoping
for that now the Knight might have to
move let's say to H5 then White Knight
captures an H5 and so on but hunt just
plays D captures on e4 he offers the
Knight on F6 to play e captures on F3
and completely bust open white skiing
side so there's really nothing better
than to play Queen captures on F6 so
this is what Christopher does now comes
he captures on F3 notice how the bishop
and C6 makes all of this possible as uh
in all of the games previously that have
reached that position the bishop was
traded for a knight on F5 but Han just
played H6 and kept the bishop alive so
here we have Knight the F5 and also
another crucial moment in the game where
if you really want to try and save this
with white you have to offer a queen
trade and then just hope for the best
but it's still very very very hard to
play this for example if a rook uh some
like Rook B to G it goes after the
Knight you want to put pressure on that
G2 Pawn how do you play this problem is
if you trade Queens uh right away after
King captures on D7 and Knight to F5 you
just get this Droid root captures on G2
now if you go to H1 work captures an H2S
Checkmate then if you go King to F1 then
Bishop to B5 check and again you will
get checkmated Rookie 2 now just Rook
captures threatening Rook to H1
Checkmate and after King to E1 uh just
The Rook captures with checking the D1
and Rook to H1 Checkmate so that's not
gonna work however after this queen F5
and Rook D to G8 you could try Rook the
E8 with check it is a possibility so
just trying to get the Rook away from
the G file any through capture Sunny 8
then Queen captures and these seven King
captures Knight captures 98 Rook
captures and only now you develop with
Knight to C3 and you would get this
position where it's not at all
comfortable for white but after F Cal
press and G2 black is up upon it's uh
it's a protected fast Pawn on G2 but
still white would be able to play this
at least you have a fast age Pawn you
have a rook ready to jump in the open D
file you have a knight uh so you know
maybe maybe it would be possible to
defend this however after the are moving
the game Knight to F5 Rook DT G8 by Hans
and now yes white is up at night but
look at all of these undeveloped pieces
so Knight the G3 stopping Rook captures
on G2 now hunts even takes a moment to
get his King to a bit of a safer Square
he plays King to B7 as it doesn't appear
that white has any moves left here Ponte
A4 trying to get that Rook into the game
and now it's actually a forced Checkmate
in 12 or however many moves you want as
well there are many possibilities here
but it's not going to be possible to
defend this for white so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
absolute uh brilliancy of a maneuver
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on going right uh for
the white king and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Rook captures on H2 a very nice
Rook sacrifice that of course can never
be accepted if you play King characters
on H2 then again only one winning move
you have to be very precise Queen to G4
and now there is no way to defend this
if you play Queen E5 to guard the knight
uh F2 uh not only attacking The Rook but
also taking away the G1 Square from the
white king now Queen H4 will just be
Checkmate so there's no stopping this
see if you try something like rookie 4
it's a it's a silly move but then F1
Queen and now everything is Checkmate if
you if you move the knights to capture
the queen then just Queen captures on G2
if you move the Rook to capture this
queen uh then the bishop and queen combo
delivers Checkmate on G2 so I mean it's
complete mess of a position so I have to
Rook captures on H2 uh Christopher as he
did play A4 he plays Rook to A3 tries to
get that Rook to help out with the
defense but now Rook captures on G3 and
after Rook to B3 check Hans just played
King to A7 obviously why he put the King
on B7 and he was in this position on
move 22 that Christopher you resigned
the game and what a spectacular victory
for black in the Berlin defense after
that crazy crazy line so here there's
just no move you can make I mean
everything is just gonna capture on G2
and that's it you could try running away
with the King but it's a matter of a
simple a few checks for example F2 now
opens up a discover check King E2 Queen
to E8 with the check and now it doesn't
really matter where you go to D1 where
you can just capture here bring another
queen into the game deliver Checkmate so
really whatever you want to do so uh
very nicely played by black uh it's a
really a beautiful line in the Berlin
defense especially here after F5 just
throwing in this H6 and deciding to keep
the bishop on this diagonal for some
reason no one ever did this before uh
but it definitely makes sense the bishop
belongs uh much better on this diagonal
and it's uh well it's just a a beautiful
beautiful game but like I said the the
moves that really allowed this uh all to
happen for black are this bishop
captures and H6 just going for material
like this and another one not trying to
actually hold hold this game but still
trying to preserve the extra piece and
hope to maybe even win the game uh but
yeah those were the the two big mistakes
that that Christopher made and that
allowed this 22 move Brilliance to occur
uh as well uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it as I've seen there was a
lot of talk about this game and I've
seen the final position but I've haven't
seen the game so I decided to check it
out I I did enjoy it you know almost uh
you know it gets you to maybe pick up
the Berlin defense for your own games
but you know almost not really uh so
yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it another nice one in the Hunts
Neiman Saga I would like to thank Sarah
medrata Michael ovens ravishing reptiles
YouTube uh James daughter and lubok and
where is agal matrino for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day